Glenn Greenwald is host of system update
on Rumble he joins us tonight to assess
this Glenn thanks for coming on for the
second time that we know of the bite
Administration has shut down any attempt
to reach a brokered ceasefire why do you
think that is
from the very beginning it's been clear
that the U.S wants this war to continue
and wants it to go on for as long as
possible because they have no interest
in protecting Ukraine they instead want
to sacrifice Ukraine have Ukraine
destroyed in order to advance what they
think is the United States political
interest geopolitical interest of
weakening Russia and the way to do that
is to use Ukraine as a pawn kill as many
ukrainians as possible destroy their
whole country if they have to in order
to prolong the war as long as possible
and the response of the US government
and his Defenders has been we don't have
any position about when the war ends
that's completely up to the ukrainians
when they want to end the war they can
end the war if they don't we'll support
them and the lie just got revealed if
you listen to what John Kirby said they
asked him are the ukrainians willing to
have a ceasefire and he said not only
won't they we won't allow it either
essentially admitting finally what's
long been obvious of the country funding
the war providing the arms for the war
which is the United States determines if
and when the war ends and we obviously
you don't want that word end
how are people who are pushing for the
sacrifice of more Ukrainian and Russian
children for whatever it's worth how did
they seize the moral High Ground in this
conversation they're Monsters how do are
they allowed to lecture the rest of us
about human rights
so there's a propagandistic narrative
from the beginning that the ukrainians
are feisty courageous and are fighting
for their own country and we ought to
stand by their side the reality is the
complete opposite the ukrainians do not
want this war to continue you zielinski
is not using a voluntary Army he's using
a conscript Army he is drafting these
people who are unwilling to fight and
has repeatedly in the last four months
on three occasions increase the
punishments for desertion or for people
who are otherwise rebelling against this
war because the ukrainians know that
they're being used as cannon fodder for
the interest of other people around the
world so it's a conscript Army they're
forcing these ukrainians to go and die
in huge numbers for things that are not
in their interests what's in their
interests is to negotiate with the
Russians over an agreement that will
allow Ukraine into Ukraine Ukraine to
keep the parts of their country that
want to be ruled by Kiev and it's the
United States and Great Britain that are
blocking it purely for our own interests
yeah and then then they're lecturing you
all right Glenn Greenwald I appreciate
it thank you so much for that analysis
that analysis
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight